- Please welcome the
magnanimous Jennifer Aniston.
(audience cheering)
- I know, we can't hug.
It's so stupid.
- I'll also just like get
down, do some of that.
(Drew chuckling)
- Hi, babe.
Hi.
(audience cheering)
This is...
First of all, seeing you in the flesh
'cause I have been watching this
and you're so good.
You're so good
(audience cheering)
at this.
Honestly, I love every single bit of it.
You get stains out of your (beep).
I mean, someone said
to me, oh what was it?
- Put a stain on the chair.
- Well, I've already put
a stain on your chair
'cause of my body makeup.
(Drew panting)
You're like dying for that, right?
This has been in your
blood for a long time.
- Yes, yes, it really did start
when I was like 14 living
in my first apartment,
and then there was a
laundry mat down the street,
and I would get into that washer,
like it was a cauldron and I was a witch.
(Jennifer chuckling)
Fabric softener, stain removal, bleach,
the whole art of,
and I think that's where it was born.
- And also, the whole
sentence, 14, my own apartment.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- This girl has lived it.
- Well, we're going
through a journey today.
- Yes.
- And I wanted to take this intimate tour
of Los Angeles that
really showed every place
that I've lived.
- Do you still have the house
that I've been to a few times?
- I sold it actually.
- No.
- I know.
That was a very painful thing for me,
a very scary thing for me
to leave my one anchor.
- That was your anchor.
- When you moved from New York to LA,
what were the feelings?
What was that experience like
to let go and start anew?
- Yeah, well, let go and start anew.
I don't think anybody
going from New York to LA
ever actually says I'm moving.
You're going on a vacation
(audience chuckling)
that then just keeps extending itself
'cause you're almost too
afraid to say as an actor,
I'm gonna go try to make it in California
'cause I didn't make it
in New York for two years.
God knows, I'm gonna make it in LA,
so I'm just gonna go visit my father.
And then I landed and I knew one person
and then I met another person
who then introduced me.
And then I went into this little party,
like a little house party in Laurel Canyon
with maybe 12 people.
Next thing you know,
I'm in a goddess circle in Laurel Canyon,
and all of a sudden I couldn't just talk,
you have a talking stick.
I was like wow, I have
landed in Los Angeles.
And then I got a job at
a telemarketing company,
I don't even know where it was.
- What were you selling?
- Pocono time shares.
And I did get a job.
So I moved from Studio City
where I met these people,
this group of people,
and they all had rentals on
this street in Laurel Canyon
called Beechenal Road.
- Yep.
- One lived here, one lived here,
one lived here and they would
all sort of visit each other.
There was one house that
everyone kind of congregated in.
And then one night I was there.
They were like this
one's available for rent.
So then I got myself up on the hill.
And we were called the Hill People.
(audience chuckling)
Lived this fun few years,
doing jobs here and there,
and then "Friends" happened,
which I thought I'd kind of manifested
'cause I said this is sort
of the way I live on the hill
where you have your friends
and everybody shows up at the house,
at Monica and Rachel's.
I was like I feel very,
this is very familiar to me.
- Do you believe that
you do manifest things,
like one is capable of manifesting?
- I've been told to
manifest whatever it is
that you are wanting to manifest.
You speak to it as though
it's already happened.
- Okay, I like that.
- So thank for this wonderful job
that I have dreamed about and prayed for,
and with this glorious crew,
and a joyful experience.
Thank you for that.
(audience cheering)
- Now, it's hard to
like pass by the career
that you've had and jump to the next one
and then we're gonna go
backwards but Adam Sandler
(audience cheering)
who is someone that.
- [Jennifer] The Sandman.
- [Drew] The Sandman.
- [Jennifer] The Sandman can.
- [Drew] Adam is, he's
one of a kind, isn't he?
- He's a unicorn.
- Yes, he really is.
- He's a unicorn
'cause he walks with joy, lives with joy
and he doesn't get moody.
Yeah, comedians are moody.
- And I'm attracted to them
because I want them to
make me laugh in real life.
- Yes, let your girlfriends do that.
- Yeah, totally.
- Yeah.
- So there was this Twitter debate
that happened about who's a better partner
for Adam Sandler, Jennifer
Aniston or Drew Barrymore,
which sounds weird to say my name.
And what I loved about
what came out of that was.
- What?
- Well, that you and I chose each other.
- Oh, well, that's a no-brainer.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
That's because there's the
phrase that guys like to say.
Bros before hoes.
- Oh my God, I was gonna
say hoes before bros.
- Always.
- And that is sisterhood.
- [Jennifer] That's right.
- And we have had that
and you have it with your friends.
And we just celebrate that
and I loved that that
was the truth answer.
(upbeat music)